while the impending release of Dark
Souls 2 has some gamers shaking in their
stylish yet affordable boots this video
is for those of you who are up for a
challenge now the soul series is
notoriously difficult but I've got five
games for you that are even harder if
you're up for a challenge and some
broken controllers then be sure to stay
tuned I'm a huge adventure game fan but
there does come a point where puzzling
is no longer fun and that's basically
when it loses all semblance of logic or
sense while recent games like Deponia
began to suffer from this pretty badly
in its later installments it doesn't
hold a candle to the bag full of
nonsense that was Discworld there should
always be an element of difficulty to
solving puzzles and all the titles like
this one were amongst the best of them
but it shouldn't boil down to halting
someone snoring by putting a frog in
their mouth then scaring and
subsequently catching a butterfly to use
on a lamppost so that a monk in the
future will get zapped by lightning and
remove his robe no just just know the
world loved and critically acclaimed
ninja gaiden black came with two
difficulty settings the easy one was
called ninja dog and treated you like an
idiot the entire time for deciding to
play on easy the other option was called
master ninja and made some gamers want
to weep on the floor the boss fights
were downright unforgiving the mechanics
hard to master and the enemies never
seem to do that handy Assassin's Creed
thing where they'll politely hang back
for a few seconds until you're done
wiping the floor with whichever enemy
happened to be in front of them in the
queue of steady inevitable death
unfortunately in ninja garden black that
inevitable death was usually your own
also look forward to persistently being
asked if you'd like to lower the
difficulty setting after your many many
epic defeats
everybody wants to be the guy the guy
saves the day he jumps the jumps to bang
crushes the foes and solves the puzzles
even our very own Eric Tay wanted to be
the guy it didn't work out so well
puzzle-platformer I want to be the guy
really just wants to screw you over Eric
found that out the hard way when he
discovered the game really wants to just
kill you over and over again and it
doesn't care how angry you get in the
process begins essentially the
non-sentient version of the dude who
can't stop laughing at videos of people
falling over except instead of falling
over you'll be defeated by invisible
spikes and disappearing platforms I want
to be the guy wants to see you fail a
whole lot and you will when asked if
you'd still like to be the guy Eric T
replied no before retreating to the
fetal position Anna whispering over and
over why was there an invisible platform
there I don't understand
for my final two there really was no
other choice other than to go retro
because NES games don't give a [ __ ] if
you finish them or not first up I've got
the completely unforgiving Battletoads
Battletoads have the kind of levels that
would leave you in a cold sweat late at
night as you relived falling off that
final platform and being sent all the
way back to square one Battletoads isn't
a troll game like I want to be the guy
but it definitely wants to see you fail
hard then again it's one of those games
where all that failure adds up to one
glorious victory if you can make it past
all the rage quits and angry weeping the
one game that beats all others to ending
game is sanity though was contrast
special mentions to super ghouls and
ghosts and Zelda 2 The Adventure of Link
but this one's a real [ __ ] yet another
example of a game that doesn't care
about you or your willingness to stick
it out contra makes you save Planet
Earth from aliens and unlike more recent
apocalypse preventing games this time
it's exactly as difficult as it sounds
with one hit kills galore the game was
so hard that most people only completed
it thanks to the famous Konami code
which gave you 30 lives as opposed to
the poultry original offering of 3
as with any just ever
that I'm unfortunately restricted to
giving you only five examples so make
sure you let me know what you reckon the
hardest game of all time is in the
comments down below and let me know what
you reckon I've missed out on good luck
if you try to attend to any of these
games and I'll see you next week special
mentions to super ghouls'n ghosts and a
venture of link zelda to adventure to
the big venture of link sells its here
just super ghouls and ghosts and let
think living soul oh my god venture tube
I don't know super ghouls'n ghosts and
until the - I want to say adventure -
and adventure -